[Applause]
hello hello hello
[Music]
hello to everyone in our vfs
today we are celebrating veterans day
uh the term bff usually stands for
um virtual friends and family but today
it's veterans friends and family because
each and every one of our bffs our
veterans so we are
so honored to be with you today
i spoke to you in the control room over
trevor's headset
is he not the best camp counselor i just
love him you have to know what a good
person
he is and you know helps shepherd and
just make sure this whole experience is
is good for
everyone who comes to visit us which is
so kind of anyone to spend their time
hanging out with us and trevor really is
the man
so i also wanted to say hello to debbie
debbie are you there hi debbie
hi how are you drew how are you today
i am great how are you doing i'm really
happy to be here
especially on this most important day
and
i understand that you're about to retire
after almost 38 years
in the armed forces
yes ma'am thank you
and by the way not to sound like shallow
girl stuff but you don't look old enough
to have been in the armed forces for 38
years you're
looking beautiful and so young that's
what i'm going for
it's working you look young and fresh
i'm like 38 years
debbie when how um what are you looking
forward to doing
when you retire the most
well um i'll be 60.
so um my husband and i are planning on
getting a truck and a camper and going
out west and visiting our we have a son
in
yellowstone national park and another
one that's in la
that works in the film industry too and
so it's what we're looking forward to
doing is just traveling and
seeing the seeing the country well when
you retire debbie please call me because
i'm not allowed to send you something
right now but i have gifts waiting for
you okay
and we can like talk beauty regime and
everything
please please please uh call me as soon
as you retire
in one year from now yeah okay good
let's get into that camping trip talk
moisturizers and like
gosh you are beautiful inside and out
thank you for visiting with us today
so are you oh so are you drew thank you
so much
thank you debbie i hope to live up to
that
i will do my best every single day thank
you
my goodness thank you thank you thank
you
a great way to honor veterans today or
any day
is to support veteran organizations like
operation gratitude wounded warrior
project
i-a-v-r-i-a-v-a there are actually
very many and if you go to our website
you can find all the ones that we've
put up um in case you would like to look
at that and get involved and
i can't think of any individuals that
embodies
our word of the week more than veterans
because our word of the week is
intrepid that's right it's characterized
by resolute fearlessness fortitude and
endurance and by the way our studio is
practically adjacent to the uss intrepid
that's right we see it every day an
aircraft carrier that's now a historic
landmark and museum
the uss intrepid was full of one of the
most successful
well it was the most one of the most
successful battleships in u.s history
and it served tours
in world war ii the cold war and the
vietnam war and i highly recommend
taking a tour if you are able to
you